how are you Bob good always happy to be
on with the voice of reason now wait a
minute you know that's a hashtag that's
I use yeah design I think it's brilliant
okay it's brilliant the voice of our II
son ASOS right exactly now but Bob that
means you're on Twitter is that what
that means that you see that I'm now on
social media no no actually actually it
doesn't but things somehow filter
through the ether and randomly get to me
now I imagine in your career Bob there
have been people that did try to
convince you to get on Twitter correct
that that conversation did happen
somebody did say to hey Bob what if we
open you an account or something like
that I have to do that that conversation
yeah that conversation took place
I don't know several years ago at NBC
where the idea and I guess this is the
idea everywhere networks local stations
hashtags something or other you know
you'll be in a hotel someplace on some
assignment you're in Cleveland and
somebody's reporting from the school
board meeting yes and it's like at Sally
Jones yes well you know I can't get
enough of Sally Jones thoughts I just
want to find out what's happening to
school for me I can't even vote in
Cleveland but I think I'll follow Sally
Jones yeah it might be a better person
for that but you know so I guess they
want you to do it sure and when they
brought it up at this meeting at NBC
how'd that go it was like yeah not that
Bob Costas because you could you know I
mean you you know how to communicate in
probably this is back in the day it was
just a mere 140 characters you can you
can communicate out and in length or
brevity that's the soul of wit as you
know Bob so I'm you know yeah that's
that's Shakespearean on your part thank
you sir about this the brevity being the
soul of witness but as as you as you
know the one thing I long for is even
more exposure to the American public
more attention I'm trying to build a
career here rich and as you in this
world it's largely because of the
internet mm-hmm anything you say
anything you say you could say I think
it would be a good idea to give milk to
orphans by the time that gets to the
fourth or fifth iteration it's been
twisted into something that doesn't
remotely resemble what you've actually
said what you actually believe so if
that's going to happen anyway even in
the normal established channels yes why
does the sane person want to expose
themselves to even more of this insanity
hmm by being on Twitter so that they put
something out there and eight zillion
people they've never met respond to it
and by the time it gets to the prison
4/16 person forget about the eight
zillions it's a complete distortion of
everything that you said why so you're
saying this so you're saying there's a
chance Bob you're saying there's a small
infinitesimal chance you'd like Jordan
saying his chance of coming back many
many moons ago like that pretty much
yeah I would think there was a much
better chance of Norden coming back
there's a much better chance of Michael
Phelps all of a sudden deciding only
months out I'm gonna swim in Tokyo Bob
Costas here on the Rich Eisen show let's
let's get into some of the matters at
hand we spoke at length about the Astros
cheating scandal when it was in full
bloom with the commissioners report
being out there and everybody having
been involved lost their jobs if the
Commissioner could take a mulligan on it
now that we've heard the players be so
full throated in their response Bob do
you think what would that look like if
Manfred was given a mulligan here same I
think the only possible thing would be
to consider vacating the title or
placing an asterisk next to it for 2017
his thinking was that there was no
precedent for that that people who even
have a superficial understanding of
baseball history know about the 1919
Black Sox people have a mental asterisk
alongside Barry Bonds and whomever else
during the steroid era no matter what
the record book nice they say that was
his thinking I don't think he
anticipated and maybe none of us did the
whirlwind of response one spring
training began and once microphones are
placed in front of those players and I'm
sure you've commented on this in the
last few days yourself during the
steroid era and we be naive to think
it's completely gone but it's greatly
greatly reduced because of testing and
penalties but at the height or depth if
you prefer of the steroid era players
would mumble about it anonymously or off
the record or they'd speak in
generalities we need testing but they
never called individuals out and I guess
the reason is that every clubhouse had
at least some PE D users in it whereas
players as a group now feel that 29
teams were victims and the one team the
Astros were the perpetrators whether
that's exactly true or not I think
that's the general feeling then you
throw in social media and a generation
of players much more inclined to make
their every thought public you've got a
different situation than just a
generation ago and so I guess the one
thing that Manfred might consider if he
could start over
would be vacating the title or some kind
of official indication that this
championship in 2017 is tainted Bob
Costas you're on the Rich Eisen show
when do you think the they release the
Red Sox report I mean that has to happen
before opening day right I mean we got
to get that out well yeah here we are on
Tuesday and last week at his press
conference Manford said by the end of
next week so that means in the next few
days what do you think will glean you
got any best guests here let's guess
well Alex Alex Cora has already gotten
whacked and the sense you get from the
Red Sox will see the sense you get from
the Red Sox is that the penalties on the
team they don't expect the penalties on
the team to be all that great Cora lost
his job probably related more to his
role with the Astros in 2017 we'll see
we'll see what happens I just don't know
what the evidence is that the
commissioners investigation has
uncovered regarding the Red Sox so I'm
not going to speculate Bob Costas here
on the Rich Eisen show let's now remove
the
Paul hat and put on if you will the
basketball shoes I don't know that's
just a terrible analogy or segue but I
just try to move in fact that you spent
many years you're the one who wants the
Mulligan forget about man alright yeah
I'll call a 20-second timeout I'm
touching my shoulders right here Bob
your years of calling NBA on NBC and the
years in which you watched kobe bryant
perform in the amount of you what were
your thoughts on yesterday's kobe
memorial here in los angeles I thought
it was magnificent obviously a sad
occasion but in a sense it was an
uplifting event everyone was pitch
perfect and it's one thing to have good
intentions but that was a beautifully
produced memorial and I say that with
respect the way they laid it out the way
each thing led seamlessly into the next
everybody hit a different note but they
all hit notes perfectly people are going
to focus on Vanessa of course so
heartfelt and seeing Michael Jordan that
way with tears streaming down his face I
think that was endearing as any of us
have ever seen Michael Jordan and you
know we heard in the aftermath of his
death and also in the latter stages of
his career in post retirement we heard
about Kobe the man in full his wide
range of interests his desire to become
good at things beyond basketball his
interest in women's sports how giving he
was as a friend and with charities his
devotion to his family we heard about
all those things as a generalization but
then when you watch this memorial
yesterday and everyone in their own way
Illustrated so authentically those
varied aspects of Kobe's textured life
and textured personality that really
brought it all home you got a good story
could Kobe story from when you were
covering him calling his games anything
first met him
in comparison to other you know I knew
him pretty well in the early stages of
his career when he broke in in 96 the
NBA was on NBC and we had it through
2002 so we had it through the three
consecutive Laker championships at the
beginning of the century I didn't cross
paths with Kobe much at all in the last
15 years or so but I interviewed him for
the first time when he was 18 years old
in 1996 and I was struck even then I
remember saying to people even then this
kid is so mature
he's so self-possessed he's so different
from many of his peers and of course
that's attributable to spending all that
time in Italy being the son of an NBA
player his whole background was
different than most of his peers and
even then I sensed in him an active
intelligence and curiosity he was 18
years old he was asking me about
broadcasting he was asking me about the
various things that I had done I found
him much more interesting than I thought
he should have found me but he was
asking me questions off-camera and then
as his career developed and you've
noticed this in athletes yourself rich
talent is one thing great talent is one
thing but there's an element of an
athlete's character I'm just talking
about athletic character here where
somebody wants the ball or wants to be
at bat in the most pressure-packed
situations when he was only 21 22 years
old he was like that Doug Collins and I
were calling the NBA Finals in 2000
between the Lakers and Pacers game four
in Indianapolis Lakers up two games to
one if the Pacers win the game obviously
the series is even in Game five is in
Indy late in the game
Shaq fouls out the game goes to overtime
Kobe who's what 21 22 at that point just
takes that game by the throat just takes
it over and you can sense the presence
in him which goes went beyond Talent
like I was made for moments like this
and there are certain athletes who feel
that way I remember once asking Reggie
Miller in an interview what if you're
having a bad night what if you're 1 for
13 on three-pointers and with 5 seconds
to go
timeout ball at half-court the balls
gonna go in your hands you're 1 for 13
what are you thinking he said I'm
thinking I'm gonna be 2 for 14 you have
to have that kind of athletic courage or
a sense of yourself to rise to the
occasion as Kobe did so many times you
know and and I mentioned it earlier on
the show with Michael Wilbon and also my
my cohort for the show for the day who
you know very very well her name is
Susie Schuster she's right over there
Jenni pretty much and I mentioned that
to me the speaker that really hit me
outside of obviously his wife was
Michael Jordan and the fact that when
when Kobe came into the league he made
no bones about wanting to be better than
Jordan and pretty much the whole world
saying Yeah right good luck with that
and for Jordan to get up there and speak
at his memorial I just blew me away Bob
that that this was actually happening
and speaking of Kobe in that manner IIIi
can't put it into words I'm wondering if
you could well as I said earlier I think
that was about as endearing as we've
ever seen Michael Jordan in a public
setting and no one could deny how
genuine how authentic it was there was a
whole lot of grace at the Staples Center
yesterday in various ways and as I said
earlier I think when when it was over
with from different directions different
aspects of his life and his
relationships people got a pretty good
sense of Kobe Bryant the man in full hmm
it was something else at me Sue's you
were there yesterday and you sense the
same thing as well yeah we were all
surprised we were surprised Bob at how
tender Michael was because yes he
alluded to it in his speech that Kobe
was annoying he'd text him at 2:00 in
the morning
the morning but we saw a really tender
side to Michael and I wonder if it's
from aged experienced the solemnity of
it all because it was as big as the
Staples Center was Bob it was so
intimate on the floor there amongst the
trainers who worked on him and the
cohorts the the classmates if you will
of Kobe Bryant because really the NBA
was his college and we were all taken
aback by this side of Michael which like
I said perhaps his age perhaps its
experience perhaps it's watching
somebody die before him that revered him
but it was a side of Michael that he
doesn't let people see very often yeah
and it was appropriate in this situation
I think it's all the things you cited
Suzy and it was intimate it was intimate
in a very large setting just as he said
and this is only one small aspect of it
and it's not the most important aspect
but my sense is that Michael Jordan who
obviously is keenly intelligent and
aware of what's going on around him that
as he's moved into his 50s and as he's
matured there'll always be some
competitive fire but that mellows a
little bit and he has every reason to
feel fully secure in terms of his place
in basketball history in the history of
sports and this is a rough analogy I
knew Ted Williams very well toward the
end of his life and Ted was always very
giving in his assessment of other
players you never felt as if he felt any
need to remind anyone of what he had
done his place in history was set and I
sense in that little way that Michael is
the same his achievements are
unassailable his standing is
unassailable that allows you to be as
generous as is appropriate to everyone
else well Bob I appreciate everything
as I now head off to an event Susy that
we all know is an annual event for the
National Football League many people
think that my run is a tradition at the
combine but there is a tradition few
people know about
it's the moment I'm on the air my phone
buzzes I look down and it's a text from
Bob Costas telling me how insightful he
feels the combine is and how informative
it is and how the minutiae is beyond
appropriate Bob am I gonna get that text
yeah this actually the the only thing I
truly look forward to yes is your sprint
and your times have declined a little
bit expected yes but apart from that yes
I live to see how some potential fifth
round draft choice out of Appalachian
State and negotiates those cones
complete that is the pinnacle of sports
excitement yeah because and you're on
the edge of your seat when you text him
I couldn't sense it I can sense it I
read between the lines of that text that
about how you can't wait for the moment
that the most arcane drill that used to
be run back in the 50s is still being
run in 2020 to try and determine
somebody's ankle flexion as well as
their if you will hand sighs potentially
might factor into a game in week 13 in
year seven of their career Bob Wright
everyone knows that
well the combine is on they are not to
bother me I have my meals brought in I
knew it Bob I knew it
Jill brings in the TV dinner that's
right Salisbury steak take care of
yourself Bob really appreciate the call
well chat soon
by rich by sir you gotta there's Bob
Costas none other right here on the Rich
Eisen show for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel - 39 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app